[Music]  every day  [Music]  is earth day  it's the soil we step on the air we  breathe  the water we drink the food we eat  the forests oceans  and mountains surrounding us  our home  science is clear  we are overpassing every single tipping  point of the planet's boundaries  pushing it to its absolute limits the  latest ipcc reports warn us that the  window of opportunity to act is closing  but there is still a chance to restore  our biodiversity and reverse the  worrying climate trends that unbalance  our planet  and for that  we must cut down our emissions  significant invest in renewables  and stop our dependency on war  funded fossil fuels  with cop 15 for biodiversity coming up i  call on all leaders to demonstrate the  leadership our world needs right now  let's not leave our future slip off our  hands  less words more actions for this earth  day